public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
conseiller politique de françois fillon
dont il supervise le projet eric woerth
est l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être avec
nous présent à ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp avec les échos et avec
radio classique vous répondrez à trois
grandes questions eric woerth la
première vous sera posée tout à l'heure
par jean-francis pécresse françois
fillon passe t-il à la médecine douce et
pas que dans le domaine de la santé
deuxième question françois fillon
doit-il trouvé son point d'équilibré ce
qu'il a du mal à fédérer entre les
sarkozystes alain juppé alain juppé qui
donnent de la voix aujourd'hui vous
répondrez à nadège paul jacques enfin
troisième question moi ou le chaos est
ce si ce qu'il dit votre candidat pas
seulement à ses amis des républicains
mais à l'extrême droite et à la gauche
concernant leurs programmes que l'on
découvre peu ou prou de jour en jour
mais d'abord une première question
d'actualité
car l'actualité à l'instant présent ce
sont les sondages même si bien sûr on le
sait françois fillon s'en est toujours
méfié mais l'institut et lab le placent
désormais nettement devant emmanuel
macron donc à la deuxième place 20 % + 3
points pour votre candidat contre 17
pour l'ancien ministre de l'économie qui
enregistre une chute de cinq points
marine le pen elle est toujours
largement en tête
est ce que pour vous c'est un croisement
des courtes que vous attendiez est ce
que c'est une première victoire a coûté
pour relativiser tout seul à la victoire
si au moment de l'élection on verra au
premier tour et puis au deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle en tout cas on
prépare ça avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
sérieux et françois fillon aujourd'hui
étape la danse a dans sa campagne c'est
a évidemment un croisement des courbes
c'est important pour nous de retrouver
la seconde place qu'on avait perdu
pendant quelques quelques temps quelques
jours au profit de monsieur macron voilà
je suis macron perd du terrain au fur et
à mesure du temps qu'il essaie
d'expliquer ou plutôt qu'ils n'essayent
pas d'expliquer son projet ça vient ça
vient il va tout déballer le 2 mars
oui enfin il avait quand même le temps
il est en campagne depuis maintenant des
mois et des mois et pourrait dire des
choses il dit des choses qui sont tout à
fait contradictoires en général mais
c'est un verger des courbes selon vous
elle est irréversible maintenant je
l'espère en tout cas le potentiel de
progression de françois fillon est très
important françois fillon a été un score
plus important à un moment donné il est
baissé donc il peut reconquérir une
bonne partie de l'électorat qu'il avait
perdu pour des raisons extérieures à sa
campagne monde extérieur avec impatience
hommage auquel ont adhéré
donc on peut considérer que le potentiel
de progrès de françois est très
important j'ai aucun doute que jour
après jour semaine après semaine au fur
et à mesure du déroulement de la
campagne sur le fond et de ses
propositions pour la france
françois retrouve l'étiage qui était
alors vous parlez d'éléments extérieurs
à sa campagne mais qui sont quand même
très lié à la personnalité de françois
fillon est ce que vous redoutez ce pas
d'autre surprise est ce que vous l'avez
demandé par exemple 2
de dire s'il y avait encore des choses à
redouter moi je ne je ne redoute rien
d'ailleurs françois et plus toi mais
vous à reims la fusion est parfaitement
détendu là dessus dans les françois
fillon il n'a pas le sentiment d'avoir
agi contrairement à la loi il pour
savoir respecter la loi et c'est ce que
je crois aussi maintenant chacun y va de
son interprétation dans a parlé pendant
trois semaines que de ça 24 heures sur
est-ce que ça revienne avec d'autres
informations il ya apparemment demain
dans le canard enchaîné mais allez
savoir les semaines qui viennent je ne
crois pas puis la vie de 9 à l'aller la
france ne vit pas au rythme d'un journal
enfin est ce que c'est que ces histoires
donc france mais on n'avait pas de
répartie dans sa campagne pourrait pas
demander de vous rassurer
non enfin on a eu des discussions comme
toujours avec vous à les rassurer mais
il n'a pas besoin de me rassurer je
pense que françois c'est le meilleur
candidat que nous puissions avoir
d'abord parce qu'il est issu la de la
primaire dont il est incontestable pour
nous on fait bloc derrière lui tous les
tous les tous les élus des républicains
et de l'udps et y font bloc derrière
françois fillon l'a démontré même même
contre vents et marées merci au revoir à
continuer avec jean francis pécresse
le directeur de la rédaction icloud
néoclassique qui nous rejoint maintenant
enfin la rance et bonsoir michel bonsoir
eric woerth la cour des comptes par
exemple estiment qu'en 2017 il faudrait
faire six milliards d'euros d'économies
dans l'assurance maladie ou est-ce que
vous les faites la dérive la dérive
automatique des coûts dans la santé
c'est à peu près 7 7 milliards d'euros
chaque année si vous n'en ferez
maintenir d'où nous nous nous nous
souhaitons divisé par deux cette dérive
en divisant par deux ce rythme de dérive
par une meilleure organisation par par
une efficience du système de santé
faire en sorte que depuis des années
mais il faut le faire mais lisez les 25
matches qu'on a rédigé là dessus on vous
explique cette façon je pense c'est
assez fondamental le fait que le fait
qu'il ait pas de double prescription de
triple prescription le fait que
l'hôpital soit à sa place
un lit d'hôpital une hospitalisation
quelqu'un qui se présente aux urgences
sans raison de se présenter aux urgences
simplement parce que l'offre médicale à
côté n'est pas suffisante
c'est des centaines et des centaines
d'euros qui sont à chaque fois
économiser c'est un système complexe
donc ya pas une solution je sais bien
que chacun voudrait interdire
alors c'est quoi la mesure qui fait que
vous avez il n'y a pas de mesure à 20
milliards il ya des dizaines de mesures
qui conduisent à ces 20 milliards et 20
milliards c'est moins deux de ses huit
pour cent des pendant que le prélat cité
en fait vous dit pas des économies nous
avons réussi qu'à la vitalité toujours
devant le reste la qualité doit dominer
dans le système de santé en français sur
le sujet du remboursement à 100% de
l'optique pour les enfants donc ça c'est
une proposition de françois fillon ce
matin qui est une proposition nouvelle
qu'est ce que vous remboursez 100% de
quoi parce que vous vous rendez bien
compte que l'une est à 25 euros ou à 30
euros c'est pas la même chose que
lunettes de qualité un petit peu un
petit peu plus et adoptez si c'est 100%
de quoi de 100% d'une lunette de bonne
qualité c'est à dire qu'on a on définira
ce à moi ni au président de la
république de définir la qualité d'une
lunette ce sera aux professionnels de la
santé de le faire et selon des normes de
qualité
il y aura un remboursement intégral des
lunettes pour les enfants par la
sécurité sociale pourquoi la sécurité
sociale parce qu'on est bien dans cet
état d'esprit qui est de dire ce cette
solidarité
c'est ce fondement de solidarité c'est
la sécurité sociale
le pivot du système de soins du
remboursement du système de soins c'est
la sécurité sociale mais nous essaierons
d'avoir des degrés de qualité pour les
lunetterie pour les adultes les
prothèses audio de la même façon les
prothèses dentaires de la même manière
les dépassements d'honoraires aussi on
voit bien que c'est là où sont les très
gros reste à charge est sûre
l'audioprothèse vous l'avez chiffrer ses
60% de restes à charge donc il faut que
ce reste à charge ils baissent voulais
pas ça veut dire qu'il y aura un vrai
débat un débat très important avec les
professions pas avec les médecins mais
avec les professions qui livre ou qui
vendent ces dispositifs médicaux qui
font déjà beaucoup d'efforts il faut
continuer à en faire il faut qu'il ya un
marché qui secret il faut qu'ils aient
une économie il faut revoir les prix et
en même temps voilà au travers d'une
véritable politique de qualité et il y
aura un degré de qualité bien sûr ne
seront remboursés à 100% que ce qui
relève de cette qualité si vous voulez
plus que cette qualité si vous voulez
plus que cette qualité si vous voulez la
lunette avec l'alliage qui a permis aux
derniers cosmonautes d'aller dans mars
bah c'est votre problème quand vous
payez à coeur et vous payez pas demain
et vous payez à ce moment là évidemment
le supplément et les mutuelles devront
pouvoir absorber cela elles doivent
pouvoir le faire partir du moment où le
niveau des cotisations est être maîtrisé
à partir du moment où également les
coûts de gestion sont riches en carabine
c'est une discussion qu'on a eue avec
l'ensemble du secteur mutualiste ou des
assurances privées qui rembourse 1 2
question des rôles majeurs corps
chansons de fusées peut-être le la
presse se fait l'écho depuis quelques
jours à la suite des propos de françois
baroin d'une éventuelle marche arrière
sur l'augmentation du taux de la tva
intermédiaire dans le projet de françois
fillon il était question de passer cette
tva de 10 à 12% et il se dit que c'est
une proposition qui fait débat entre
vous et que vous resteriez à un taux de
10 % c'est une propre site alors c'est
une mesure pour que les téléspectateurs
et les auditeurs ne comprenne bien qui
concerne évidemment toutes les
professions de services les
restaurateurs et a donc c'est important
cette question elle se pose françois
fillon est en train de présider des
réunions d'arbitrage comme on dit c'est
à dire de décision définitive
ce qu'assure son projet
un socle vraiment très très puissant
puis allez va servir de ce socle que moi
je vais pas donner mon avis à ce stade
parce qu'il pourrait essayer qu'on
oriente et je pense que c'est à françois
fillon un moment donné c'est à françois
responsable du projet justement
justement je pense que moi je crois à la
liberté du candidat donc si je donne un
avis je suis leur soit trop proche si
cet avis j'ai donc je vois je pense qu'à
une marche de manoeuvre dans ce domaine
là qui est vous êtes très importante
voilà vous êtes nos barrages manoeuvre
une marge de manoeuvre parce qu'on
n'augmente pas et une marge de manoeuvre
françois fillon dévoilera pas idée vous
alors il a déjà beaucoup dit sur son
projet économique sur les 100 milliards
commence à l'honneur sur la baisse de la
fiscalité sur l'augmentation de la
fiscalité à les produits importés via le
taux de rivel normal alors dans le tour
de taille normal ya toutes les barres
norman lui apporter il est assez naturel
que ces produits importés c'est un peu
la tva sociale participe en réalité à la
baisse des cotisations sociales qu'elles
soient patronales ou d'ailleurs qu'elle
soit aussi salariale puisque françois
propose une baisse forfaitaire des
cotisations sociales salariales
absolument l'augmentation de la tva au
taux normal de 20 à 22% elle va se faire
qu'en et en combien d'étapes six étapes
il ya là le collectif budgétaire de
juillet 2010 est le dira le calendrier
sera sera affichée avant évidemment
l'élection
on est en train de regarder touche là on
a une opinion souvent précises moi je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse vous voyez
prendre les mesures les unes après les
autres je pense que oui je sais bien que
c'est terriblement plus important c'est
pour ça qu'il faut que ce soit un sujet
qu'il soit discuté avec les autres
sujets si vous le faites c'est parce
qu'il ya autre chose que vous faites à
côté et donc domaine économique et dans
le domaine du redressement de notre pays
tout est lié c'est le marché du travail
c'est la baisse des dépenses c'est une
réforme de l'assurance maladie parce que
c'est les retraités l'atuge en france et
sur bien sûr il ya eu ce matin une et
c'est une baisse de zappos déclarations
de françois fillon un peu curieuse qui
laissait entendre que l'augmentation de
l'âge de la retraite à 65 ans pourrait
être modulée en fonction de la durée
enfin en fonction de l'espérance de vie
donc des secteurs professionnels ou des
professions moi j'ai entendu ça j'ai
plutôt entendu françois fillon dire que
c'était quelque chose de compliqué à
faire qu'il y avait pensé moi je suis
pas favorable à ça parce que c'est
c'est infernal profession par profession
qu'est ce qu'une profession surtout
quand même là sont agriculteurs ans et
la seconde et esthéticiens est un grand
et titien ou il vous pouvez aussi une
épaisseur vous pouvez aussi régionaliser
vous vivez plus longtemps aujourd'hui
dans l'enclavé la volute là vous vous
dites que vous n'êtes pas favorable
jeudi que la pénibilité est une option
que nous avons intégré la loi 2010 et
une loi dans laquelle il y à la
pénibilité mais une pénibilité qui est
mesuré médicalement qui est de dire au
fond si vous avez une dégradation
physique qui est lié à votre vie
professionnelle alors à ce moment là
vous pouvez partir en retraite plus tôt
je pense qu'il faut en rester là même si
le débat peut se poser bien évidemment
et françois fillon a montré que ce débat
il le comprenait merci un merci saint
francis maintenant c'est nadège peljak
de l'agencé france presse qui nous
rejoint pour la deuxième grande question
de l'épreuve de vérité
l'épreuve de vérité avec la fp
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur woerth alors
alain juppé que vous connaissez bien a
dit ce matin que françois fillon devait
prendre davantage en compte les
électeurs de droite et du centre si vous
voulez gagner évidemment alors elle est
ce que monsieur fillon doit encore
trouver son point d'équilibré dans votre
famille tout le monde n'est pas
rassemblé vous savez il faut que j'ai vu
ce qu'il avait dit dans son blog rien
d'eux m'a choqué ça ça m'a semblé assez
naturel de dire aux candidats de la
droite et du centre qu'il faut qu'il
continue à rassembler les électeurs de
la droite et du centre
et puis un jour me diras semble
rassembler n'oublie pas la droite du
l'année sur gaza
mais oui droite humaniste et tu oublié
la droite s'est enfin qu'est ce que
c'est que la droite humaniste je suis de
droite républicaine somme par principe
des humanistes ça veut dire qu'on est en
intègrent une dimension humaine c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire heureusement
dans les réformes et dans dans dans ce
que nous proposons la droite humaniste
c'est celle qui permet aux français en
réalité de ne pas rester au chômage
la vraie question c'est que la gauche
humaniste elle mais les français au
chômage
la droite humaniste elle propose des
réformes pour redresser le pays
c'est pas pour faire plaisir aux
candidats c'est pour faire en sorte que
la france elle se redresse et la france
qui se redresse c'est moins de chômage
d'un pouvoir d'achat qui se développe
c'est des entreprises en meilleure santé
c'est une compétition internationale qui
profite un peu plus à la france plutôt
qu'elle ne l'affaiblît comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui
c'est aussi c'est aussi une france qui
essayent de de tuer ses vieux démons de
déficit chronique depuis des dizaines et
des dizaines d'années le projet est
quand même très strict sur le programme
radical comme l'appelle monsieur fillon
et qu'ils aillent ferait quand même pas
mal de monde
le mot radical il faut se jeter un vrai
programme voilà c'est un programme avant
par le rapport
[Musique]
radicaux s'est lui dit on était en et
alliés et partenaires on va demain
travailler évidemment et est ce que le
programme de françois fillon est radical
or vous mais c'est un programme de
réforme en profondeur de notre de notre
pays
réformer le code du travail faire que le
marché du travail soit pas à marcher du
chômage faire en sorte que le coût du
travail baisse durablement donc la
france retrouve de la compétitivité que
les entreprises soient au coeur du sujet
parce que qui produit la richesse et les
entreprises assez assez assez banal que
les médias comme assister sur pc le
nombre de fonctionnaires non pas pour se
fâcher avec les fonctionnaires mais pour
que les fonctionnaires il a un autre
avenir dans ce pays qu'ils soient mieux
payés moins nombreux mais mieux payés
avec des tâches de plus en plus à forte
valeur ajoutée que le service public
aujourd'hui en france soit d'une qualité
supérieure qu'on intègre la société du
numérique
mais j'entends bien tout ce que c'est
super mais n'empêche que alain juppé
demande aux candidats de tenir compte
des sensibilités de droite et du centre
humaniste dans le parti et là au moment
même où on parle elle est super sont
réunis qu'est-ce qu'ils font entre les
vous casse du sucre sur le dos qu'est-ce
qu'ils font pourquoi c'est pour le
besoin de se réunir mme soir dans l'est
je vous sens un peu ironique c'est pas
c'est pas du tout le cas
que chacun est une origine dans la
primaire on a soutenu alain juppé moi
j'ai soutenu nicolas sarkozy on se
retrouve évidemment autour de françois
fillon sans aucun état d'âme et je pense
qu'on l'a montré dans ces moments-là que
un certain nombre de personnes se rend
compte parce qu'on a mené campagne au
premier tour et qu'on a envie de
reparler ensemble ça me semble naturel
pour mieux encore je pense mieux
soutenir françois fillon c'est le cas de
ceux ou de celles qui se réunissent sous
la bannière d'alain juppé c'était le cas
de ceux ou celles qui s'étaient réunis à
quelques semaines ou quelques jours sous
la bannière de nicolas sarkozy il n'y a
pas d'ambiguïté
alors vous parliez justement des
candidats et va bientôt y avoir un
nouveau candidat comme vous le savez je
ne sais pas ce que fera monsieur bayrou
demain car quand même convoqué toute la
presse on imagine que c'est pour
annoncer à la presse quelque chose
d'important
peut-être sa candidature ou on dit
peut-être éventuellement son ralliement
à monsieur emmanuel macron vous
qu'est-ce que vous préféreriez qu'il se
présente il se rallie à me dire ce que
je
non mais c'est la question la réponse
soit prêt est-ce que ce que je pense que
je sais c'est que je ne peut strictement
rien monsieur bayrou l'a toujours fait
ce qu'il avait voulu donc je ne préfère
rien ce sera un fait
monsieur mais s'il vous si vous convoque
tout c'est peut-être quand même pas pour
dire qu'il fait cette sortie de la vie
politique donc peut-être que c'est pour
dire qu'il sera candidat
sinon ça devient compliqué quand même de
convoquer les journalistes pour dire
pour dire rien en fait
voilà donc c'est j'imagine qu'il sera
candidat et si les candidats bah voila
je serai un candidat de plus et on est
habituel sens monsieur bayrou depuis
très longtemps la salle en quatrième
depuis très longtemps
il est très sévère quand françois fillon
il est à la fois sur le pénélope gate et
sur le programme de purge
il est très sévère enfin il est raciste
vers deux angles d'attaqué qu'est-ce que
vous le verrez femme est grosse il est
très sévère avec tout le monde tout le
temps va peut-être pas avec lui-même est
très sévère avec tout le monde
au fond qu'a apporté françois méro la
vie politique française sur toutes ces
idées je n'en sais rien qu'at-il fait
quand il était en charge d'un ministère
aussi important que le ministère de
l'éducation nationale à rien et là que
j'ai ré avec les syndicats l'ensemble de
ce pays que son cabinet a explosé donc
il va pas donner des leçons de gestion
publique ni de leçon de courage en
politique dans s'il vous plaît donc
qu'ils soient candidats est une chose
voilà si les candidats y développera son
projet je ne sais pas ce qu'il souhaite
faire pour les français il dira appuiera
un débat et puis c'est comme ça la
démocratie c'est comme ça enfin ils
attaquent tout le temps que tout le
monde sait très bien parce que contre
fillon enfin ces derniers temps c'est ce
qu'il a fait en tout il attaqué nicolas
sarkozy de façon odieuse de façon
odieuse
enfin monsieur bayrou lille est à
l'origine de monsieur hollande
donc il faut pas non plus très
raccourcie samedi à non je raccourcis
rien il était je ne raccourcit rien ce
qui est un moment donné appelle à voter
pour ceux qui ne sont pas considérés
comme vos amis politiques c'est quand
même qu'un tout petit peu les retraites
en 2010 il ya un projet retraite faut du
courage pour tout ça il faut du courage
pour tout ça ce compliqué d'avoir du
courage en politique compliquée et vous
diriez que monsieur bayrou n'a pas de
courage en politique qu'en tire les
conclusions qui l'a pas voté une grande
loi du quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy
qui a jamais été remise en cause parce
qu'elle était juste parce qu'elle était
juste simplement fallait pouvoir
affronter l'opinion publique
sina des jeux mais se mettre en big eyes
ms2 public sénat qui nous rejoint pour
la dernière partie de l'épreuve de
vérité
bonsoir mickaël michel bonsoir alors je
vous entends depuis tout à l'heure et
j'ai l'impression en somme mais si je
peux résumer ainsi que si c'est pas
françois fillon qui devient président de
la république mais c'est le chaos
je ne veux pas dire ça le débat
démocratique il existe il ya d'autres
candidats qui sont sincères qui ont des
des propositions sincère je pense
qu'elles sont en général absolu écrit
sont crédibles je pense qu'elles ne sont
pas crédibles pour redresser notre pays
parce que je pense qu'il faut du courage
il faut aller jusqu'au bout des choses
quand madame le pen elle est toujours à
sa retraite à 60 ans qu'il considère
toujours que il faut augmenter le smic
alors que c'est que ce sera à ce moment
là créateur de chômage une augmentation
massive du suite qu'elle remet en cause
ici ou là l'euro donc l'europe d'une
certaine façon c'est assez c'est assez
criminel pour la société française c'est
à ces criminels parce qu est-ce que
c'est parce que je sais tu l'espoir
l'espoir pour notre pays de demain se
redresser
donc c'est pas ce sont des propositions
qui sont extraordinairement dangereuse
pour notre pour notre pays donc c'est
une mauvaise manière de penser mais elle
a le droit de le penser
des gens ont droit de la suivre nous on
a le droit de combattre cela parce que
ça va très très loin moi je suis un
adversaire résolu de l'extrême droite et
c'est aujourd'hui ce que représente
simple je reviendrai bien sûr sur marine
le pen dans un instant emmanuel macron
aux quelques mots parce que on a
l'impression commence à donner quelques
chiffres quelques programmes en tout cas
seront annoncés de chiffrage dans
quelques jours il a annoncé cinq
milliards pour les hôpitaux aujourd'hui
il annonce également que d'emblée il ne
respecterait les déficits à 3% pas là
contrairement à françois fillon
contrairement à fond saphir on a un
début de programme ne veut pas dire que
emmanuel macron n'a pas de points vous
plaisantez
c'est des mesures des mesures est ici ou
là il va augmenter la csg de sept mois
face à des mesures est ici ou là tout ça
dans un grand concert de banalités vous
avez vu les meetings dans lequel il dit
je mettrai fin au chômage puis l'a tant
que les gens l'applaudissent ils
applaudissent un peu pas y'a rien de ce
et d une série de banalités qui sont
absolument affligeant dont ces contraire
de l'image qui veut se donner c'est pour
ça que français je vois je voulais
attend avec impatience d une monnaie
fait un chiffrage extraordinairement
sérieux il sera présenté à un moment
donné par notre candidat par françois
fillon c'est à lui de le faire et eu un
très très gros travail
sur un ensemble de mesures complet
françois fillon est allé en discuter
avec les les allemands il a rencontré il
ya pas si longtemps madame merkel pour
discuter de tout cela
non je ne crois pas au sérieux en
réalité des propositions des manuels
macron je ne dis pas qu'il n'a pas de
proposition je ne dis pas qu'il n'est
pas en taxant excité achats deux frères
dont il en aura il est entouré d nar qui
lie et même un énarque en chef
en tout cas un économiste en chef qui
travaillait dans l'administration qui
s'occupe aujourd'hui ce sont les tcd
stratégie quand même donc comment oui
c'est un programme d d'armes quand il
dit je vous aime il dit je vous aime aux
énarques commence mais qui digérait
l'entreprise mais ça parle à tout le
monde quand il est dit je fais non mais
moi je pense que les licences des
marques avant oui je penserai et le
futur désirable ça ça vous parle le
futur désirable
oui ça c'est benoît hamon jeu oui enfin
je pense qu'il vaut mieux désiré le
futur que nous rejoindre le futur
enfin c'est pas avec ça qu'on fait un
programme présidentiel c'est avec des
choses un peu plus sérieuses parce que
si le programme de benoît hamon c'est
toujours son revenu universel dont il
commence quand même aujourd'hui à mettre
un peu de frein ces 3 ou 400 milliards
un plus personne ne sait à peu près mais
à 140 milliards sur cinq ans et
s'étoffer oui c'est forcé c'est juste
c'est juste le budget de l'état sur une
année est fondamentalement c'est quand
même lancé un signe c'est une vieille
idée pour une idée nouvelle date du
xviiie siècle
mais en même temps c'est quand même
extraordinaire de lancer un signal qui
est de dire ben c'est pas compliqué vous
pouvez ne pas travailler ne pas
travailler à un prix et voilà ce à un
prix qui est un revenu universel versé
par on sait pas qui est on sait pas
comment c'est l'appauvrissement total de
la france et c'est aussi un message mais
désastreux qui est envoyé à l'ensemble
des français ou des jeunes français je
poursuis un peu ralenti voulez bien sur
les programmes jean luc mélenchon il aa
chiffre est lui aussi son programme 273
milliards 173 de dépenses sur les
dépenses de l'état la sécurité sociale
c'est crédible à vos yeux enfin
mélenchon sur l'archaïsme en politique
c'est parti communiste je chauffe j'en
sais rien vous savez les chiffrages des
candidats jeu sa rage en na'vi sont
faites soit nancy c'est important
françois fillon il aura une trajectoire
de finances publiques
on y travaille beaucoup pour offrir un
spectacle à sa place par reviendra mais
bien sûr qu'il faut respecter mais il
faut aller en dessous de 10 à quelques
mois il doit les gueules 3%
non il avait dit que 4,7 bonjour
exerçait t'es pas cap pourquoi à partir
de la pire pourquoi mais pourquoi mais
c'était pas c'était pas c'était pas ces
mesures c'est parce qu'il anticipait sur
ce qu'a fait le gouvernement en prenant
des recettes dans l'immédiat il en
renvoyant des dépenses à l'année 2018
donc nous serons à 3% à 3 % durant le
quinquennat et 3% en aucun cas des choix
qu'en 2017 c'est compliqué en 2017 c'est
compliqué mais pour la bonne raison que
la france au mois de juillet au mois de
juin quand vous le prouver en 2018 non
mais la france au mois de juin la france
socialiste qui nous sera si on nous
gagnons il nous sera qui nous sera
livrée après l'élection à une autre
majorité cette france là elle sera pas
3%
lefa la cour des comptes l'a encore dit
donc ne ne racontons pas d'histoire elle
est à 3,3 ou à 3/4 des socialistes ils
ont fait même pas deux points sur cinq
ans même pas deux points sur cinq ans
donc il faut voir de quel endroit on
part la fonction publique a été augmenté
plus que durant toutes les cinq
dernières années
donc ils ont complètement lâché les
vannes repousser des dépenses à plus
tard et engranger des recettes qui
devait engranger également plus tard
donc franchement on n'a pas de cours à
apprendre sur le sujet mais je pense que
ce que souhaite françois fillon c'est
d'arriver à un équilibre de nos finances
publiques
en fin de quinquennat après des réformes
un écrivain oui mais pas 3%
fade donc un équilibre des finances
publiques en fin de quinquennat avec
fondée sur des réformes structurelles et
ses réformes lacs sont au coeur de son
projet et ses série formula qui ont fait
et qui doivent faire l'objet de débats
avec nos partenaires européens et
notamment la réforme du marché du
travail la réforme de la poursuite de la
réforme de la retraite la réforme de
l'assurance maladie pour lui conférer sa
durabilité
et puis la réforme du coût du travail en
france alors on est con évoqué et la
démocratisation fecq ont évoqué les
grands fonds d'un peu d'aidé
la débureaucratisation notre société
notre société est elle est trop
bureaucratisé il faut la réguler et
organiser nous on aime bien tout ça en
france on a besoin d'une administration
puissante mais on a besoin d'une
administration n'ont pas besoin d'une
bureaucratisation jean luc mélenchon oui
173 milliards de dépenses nouvelles 100
milliards d'investissements publics
grâce à des emprunts ont l'écoutent
vanter son plan à un court extrait
évidemment de son intervention de plus
de 5 heures ce week-end sur youtube
d'où ce circuit quand il a eu lieu que
tout a fini de tourner il revient 195
milliards dans les caisses de l'état
autrement dit ce sont des recettes
ab oui alors donc ça veut dire que notre
système rapportent
je sais qu'il ya des gens qu'on peut le
croire ils vont se passer vous allez
voir on va me faire dix fois le coup de
vous avez trouvé la baguette machine
alors pourquoi les autres l'ont pas fait
et ba bonnet pourquoi ils n'ont pas fait
parce que c'est pas leur intérêt alors
l'écouter à 5h sens aurait fait d'elle
castro vous ne croyez pas la relance
keynésienne de jean-luc mélenchon
non enfin enfin pas du tout enfin tout
ça c'est des cds miroir aux alouettes
c'est des fables rappelant les vertus et
des fables des séries fable racontée au
fait 195 milliards de recettes
supplémentaires personne ne paye qu'est
ce qu'ils payent 195 milliards vous
savez combien cela la tva ou là où la
siagi la cgc doit de l'ordre de 90
milliards la tva de l'ordre de 130 pire
ou sans carte via enfin vous voyez de
quel sujet il parle il veut doubler
l'imposition des défenseurs il veut tuer
les entreprises de france
il considère que c'est l'administration
qui produit les richesses non c'est pas
c'est évidemment pas seul mais c'est
parce que c'est un autre système
c'est un autre monde politique c'est en
général un monde politique qui se passe
mal
parce que quand l'extrême gauche qui est
monsieur mélenchon et l'extrême droite
se rend compte en général ils ont les
mêmes idées
évidemment ils s'aiment pas beaucoup
mais ils ont exactement les mêmes idées
et cdc des idées en général qui n'amène
pas à plus de démocratie
je vais vous entende encore sur
l'extrême droite marine le pen a je fais
une visite au liban sur une polémique
elle a refusé de porter le voile dans
quel d'une rencontre avec le moufti à
beyrouth
je ne me voyais pas at elle dit est ce
qu elle a eu raison de tourner les
talons
enfin elle a inventé un scénario elle y
est allée justement pour montrer qu'elle
ne voudrait pas porter le voile
enfin quand elle est répandue enfin
c'est un coup totalement monter vous
croyez que
madame le pen elle un pauvre is à
l'improviste ou ça vous croyez qu'elle
va voir et c'est très bien quand on va
voir le grand moufti on dirait on y va
voi eskom sort mais dans son pays
c'est ainsi on est pas on n'est pas en
france donc elle connaît exactement les
conditions de la rencontre
pourquoi communication donc c'est un
coup de communication genre je suis pas
sûr qu'on réforme notre notre pays qu'on
l'amène vers un meilleur vers un mieux
pour les français uniquement à coup de
communication bachar el-assad la
solution la plus rassurante at elle dit
a pour notre pays en termes de sécurité
contre le groupe islamique côté c'est
épouvantable bachar al assad il doit
être remis dans la wla le même sac que
que que des chauffe-eau c'est un peu la
même chose c'est la barbarie
si la barbarie donc on voit bien qu'il
ya pas de solution aujourd'hui en syrie
avec bachar al assad
vous avez dit au cours de l'émission
tout à l'heure eric woerth que vous avez
toujours combattu l'extrême droite si
marine le pen se retrouve face à
emmanuel macron au second tour de la
présidentielle qu'est ce que vous faites
je lui ai dit j'ai toujours combattu
l'extrême droite et en même temps je
vous ai dit que ce scénario là il
n'arrivera pas s ils arrivèrent me
projette pas dans les scénarios qui
arrive ou qui arrivent pas le second
tour de l'élection présidentielle ce
sera avec françois fillon contre je ne
sais pas qui on verra je ne suis pas sûr
que madame le pen soit automatiquement
qualifiés au deuxième pour le deuxième
tour je n'en suis pas sûr même si tout
laisse à penser
donc vous voulez pas nous dire que
finalement évidemment le jeu ne riez pas
à me projeter sur la corde ce soit moi
je veux que françois fillon il gagne
cette élection parce que je pense que
c'est l'intérêt du pays donc je me
projette totalement je travaille là
dessus comme tous mes collègues
d'ailleurs on fait bloc c'est ce qui
nous avait démontré au cours de cette
émission eric woerth merci d'avoir été
avec no mercy michaëlle jean sera tous à
la semaine prochaine on se retrouvera en
direct du salon de l'agriculture